Websites built with cloud code are easy
to spot. They look the same and are
clearly AI. But what if I told you this
beautiful website was built entirely
with cloud code in just a couple of
minutes. The difference isn't the tool,
it's the way you set it up. So I'm going
to show you the three levels of building
with cloud code from the most basic all
the way to the exact framework I used so
you can copy it. So by the end of the
video, you also will be able to create
this exact website I built with cloud
code. Level number one, simple
prompting. But before we can start
building websites with cloud code, we
first need an AI code editor. The best
one is Microsoft Visual Studio Code.
It's free and it has everything what we
need. So, we first download it and
install it. Once installed, you should
see something like this. The first thing
you want to do is to click here on this
icon and type in here CL code and select
the CL code plugin and click install.
Then we go here to our file system and
click open folder. Let's call it demo
one and open it. Now you should see here
on the top this little icon. It's for
cloud code. But before we can start, you
need first a clo code pro account
because then cloud code is included. And
once you're a heavy user, you can switch
easily to max account to have higher
rate limits. All right, let's get
started. We prompt no cloud code to
build the website. Build me a landing
page for cover robotics. We sell a
personal home robot called Kovo that
follows voice commands, carries things,
and learns your daily routines. By the
way, I highly recommend to also get
whisper flow so you don't have to type
everything and gives you incredible
speed to text since you can talk faster
than you can type. Let's see what
results we get with simple prompting
with cloud code. By the way, I added do
not use any skill since cloud codes is
actually using skills automatically. I
will explain skills in detail in level
two. If you don't have any skills
installed, you don't need to mention
this. All right, Clo just finished.
Let's see the results. So, this is the
result. If you want to see the website,
you click here on this file, click
reveal and finder, and simply drag and
drop this file into Chrome. And that's
what we got so far. Too much text,
generic layout, and everywhere purple
level. And there's a reason for that.
The most famous website framework,
Tailwind, used this exact color as its
default color 5 years ago, and that's
why it's all over the internet. So, I
learned that purple is the default. Even
the founder of Tailwind said, "I would
like to formally apologize for making
every button in Tailwind UI Indigo 500 5
years ago, leading every AI generated UI
on Earth also being Indigo like you can
see here also. But let's see the rest of
the website. We have here some boring
animation. Here's the typical free grid
layout we see everywhere on AI generated
websites. Here again, purple. Here's
some inconsistency in color. Too much
text again here. But in general, it
looks pretty good compared to somebody
who would do it by hand everything. But
comparing to what we want to build
today, what clo generated on the first
try, it's not really good. I mean, sure,
we could prompt it now to fix the purple
color and so on. But the problem is the
AI does not understand what you actually
want. It does not has human taste.
Another problem is it's hard to explain
what you exactly want if you're not an
expert in building websites. But the
good part is with the approach I show
you in level three, you don't have to
be. Even an absolute beginner will then
be able to create beautiful websites
like this one. Level number two, using
cloth code skills. To show you the
second approach, we will open up a new
project. So we click here, new window,
click here, open, and we create the
second folder, demo two,
and open it. Then we start Clo by
clicking on it here. And this time we
will be using a skill. To install it,
type in /plugins
and select here manage plugins. Then
type here front end and select here the
front end designed plugin. And here you
can decide if you want to install it
globally only for the project or
locally. In this case, we choose install
for you and make sure also that it's
activated. By the way, if you want to
know exactly what the plugin does, you
can click here on the source and here
you can see exactly what it does, how to
use it, and even see what's inside. For
example, this plugin only has at the end
of the day only a skill there. A skill
are basically instruction files that
tell code code how to do something like
giving it the playbook for a specific
task. For example, it says never use
generic AI generated aesthetics like
overused font families and then it gives
examples and so on. So once we install
our skill, we want to copy and paste the
whole prompt here. But this time we
don't include do not use any skill. Now
we're pasting it here and see what cloud
code generates. Now based on this
prompt, Clo decided that the front end
design skill will be useful for this
task. So he basically added the
instructions that are in this skill. All
right, Clo is finishing up. And we see
here our results. Let's open up this in
the browser. Let's open this in the
browser. First of all, good that we
don't have the purple colors anymore.
But I'm still not really impressed by
this illustration. Text looks much
better now. Oh, this looks nice. In
general, we can see the website looks
already much better. But again has this
free good layout style that we see on
all AI generated websites. But I still
don't have the same premium feeling like
on this website that we built in level
three. Here all elements look like
they're designed by a professional
designer and everything is coherent and
matches. And now finally we will build
exactly this website. Now we have level
three. I call it the ANF framework. It
stands for assemble,
normalize, fill. So the idea is simple.
Instead of describing what you want, you
give code actual components built by
real designers. Every shadow, every
animation, every detail already done.
You just pick the ones you like. This is
exactly how I built the website from the
intro, from scratch. And honestly, it's
not much harder than what we just did.
Let me show you everything step by step.
First, let's open up a new Cloud Code
project. Let's call it demo free. Next,
we go to a website called 21st.dev. Here
you have a lot of components that you
can choose from. Like for example, this
one. This one I used in the hero section
for example. And the great part about
21st.deaf is here's a feature called
copy prompt. And if I click on this, you
can select here prompt type quote code
and click copy prompt. create me a
simple website with the following
component on it. And now I paste what we
copied from 21st F and send this off. CL
code received now details instructions
how to recreate the exact same
component. Great. CL code just finished.
And it says here run the following
command
to see the website. So I click here
terminal click new terminal and paste
this command there and click enter. Now
we can copy this URL here and paste it
into this browser. And like you can see
we got the exact same component here
now. But let me show you even much
faster approach. First we delete
everything inside this folder.
Then we start a new code session. But
instead of pasting the components one by
one, we first create here a folder
called components.
Then I click this icon to create the
text file and I call it 1.xt.
Now I go back to 21st dev and click here
copy prompt. And then I paste this
prompt here. Then I create a second
file. I call it 2txt and copy the next
prompt from the component I would like
to have
and paste it here. And I continue this
approach with the following components.
By the way, in the description box
below, I also link all components so you
can try it yourself.
So once you did this, after you've done
that, you tell cloud code to create a
website with all the components inside
the components folder in order and send
this off. Now cloud code first reads all
the files and then creates the website.
Let's type in npm run dev and open this
website. Like you can see it looks
already pretty good, but it's still like
I like don't like the fonts and so on.
That's why we will first normalize the
whole web page. We got his components
from many different websites, but we
want them to look like one single
website. That's why we instruct our cl
code to normalize the whole page. For
this, we use this simple prompt here. By
the way, you can find this also in the
description box below and paste it here.
All right, clin. Let's see the results.
This here is working. Looks nice. Boom.
Yes, this looks also really nice. But
the only thing that is not not nice yet
is it's still generic information here.
For example, the reviews here are
generic. The pricing here is not for
robotics and the questions here are not
for robotics and so on. That's why we
come now to the last part of the
framework fill. But before I show you
how, I want to mention that this website
has a light mode and a dark mode. And by
the way, if you don't like anything here
from the website and so on. By the way,
like you can see the website is still
not perfect. For example, here's some
side scroll or I don't like the font and
so on. But these are simple things to
fix since you can just tell code. But
once you're satisfied with the structure
of the website and how it looks like, we
can fill it with the right information.
For that, we're using this research
prompt here. This one instructs cl code
to do some research on robotics. For
this, we open up a new clot. Paste in
this prompt and send this off. So,
basically what Clo does now is he checks
the whole website and checks what he
needs to fill out. Based on this
information, he does the research on the
topics of robots and then we instruct
him to fill out the site. All right,
code now finished his research and now
we instruct it to fill out the whole
page with this prompt here and we paste
it and send this off. So this prompt
basically instructs clo to fill out the
whole website based on our research.
Perfect. Close finished. Let's see the
results. Now he named our robot Apex.
It's a general purpose human need robot
engineer to work alongside you. It can
perceive, think and act. Now all reviews
are based on robotics. For example, here
safety was our biggest concern. After
10,000 hours of operating alongside
team, we have zero accidents. It's
flexible. It has here some pricing and
frequently asked questions for the robot
here. And this foundation you can now
use to polish your site for your exact
product. And the best part is it won't
look AI generated since we're using
components created by humans and we just
let the AI implement everything for us.
And if you like this tutorial, make sure
to join my school community where we
take you from a beginner to a pro. We
will show you exactly how to use clo
code and when to use code and when it
makes sense to use other tools, all
without the hype, just things that work.
I hope you like this video and see you
in the next